voici gérard depardieu 26 ans numéro un
du peloton des acteurs les plus demandés
en 24 mois et 7 films il est passée de
l'obscurité au salaire à six chiffres
hiver au printemps dans sa maison de
banlieue ou dans les rues de saint
germain des prés il porte les mêmes
bottes et les mêmes blouson la richesse
et la célébrité n'ont pas changé son
apparence pour tous les mariages je vais
vous raconter une histoire une histoire
très joli
il ya quelques années sans préciser
davantage n'ayant plus d'argent ou
presque et rien de particulier à faire à
terre l'envi me prie de naviguer encore
un peu et de revoir le monde de l'eau
c'est ma façon à moi de me chasser le
cafard et de ne purger dix ans moi je ne
pense pas que j'y sois un acteur parce
que le texte je sais pas ce que c'est je
le perds la moitié du temps et je
travaille surtout un a essayé d'être
disponible à l'écouté du fantasme du
metteur en scène
du grand art regarde le souffle à dos de
la cuillère moi j'ai envie de diriger
mon fantasme
comment se fait-il que presque tous les
garçons
robuste issa à la belle âme
un jour ou l'autre un désir fou de
prendre la mer des adultes m'ennuie
profondément gêne pas
j'aime pas les gens quand un costume et
m'ennuie complètement les hindous nues
trouve ridicule ridicule son lait